all right I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at long now and
thank you all for coming out on this
very warm October almost October I guess
evening I think actually my connection
to Greg started I think long before even
Greg maybe knows it but the very first
survival research laboratory show I ever
saw when I was in high school was here
in Fort Mason out in this parking lot
and it kind of changed my brain and I'd
grown up in a junkyard and Sausalito and
building things and I saw these
destructive robot theater and it it was
something that I I kind of knew I was
going to be connected to and thread
through the rest of my life
and I did a very short stint with them a
little bit and when I was in high school
but then went on to build robots for
battle bots and things like that but
several of people who work on the clock
project like Chris Rand also at some
point worked for survival research
laboratories and then when Jim Mason
started power tool drag races which was
a drag races with tools or racers made
out of hand held power tools I was
competing in that and then Greg showed
up with this wild box that was labeled
like bajillion volts on it and like
hooked it up to this saw and completely
smoked the whole class of everybody else
and like everyone realized that they
were dealing with a different species of
kind of of competitor and so I've been
paying attention ever since then I've
seen a lot of the Tesla coils that he's
worked on and brought to various shows
and so when I heard that he had a some
theories on lightning and new ways to
test out those theories I became really
interested and Michael was really great
and bringing this talk together and
working with Greg on this so without
anything further I'm gonna he's gonna
Greg's going to do a fair amount of
explanation of some of the work that
he's doing as well as the ongoing
projects and then and then I'm going to
come up and we'll have a little bit of
conversation efforts okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ireland thanks for coming out tonight
um the study of large-scale electrical
physics is an active hobby of mine it's
endlessly fascinating and surprisingly
unexplored I started this work way back
when three letter URLs were free for
their taking so visit LOD dot org if you
want to know more details about my
research tonight I'd like to talk about
three interesting electrical effects Oh
which only occur on large physical
scales Tesla's wireless power scheme
super long discharges and relativistic
effects in lightning such as the role
that Einstein's special relativity plays
during lightning formation Nikola Tesla
was an inventor who probably needs no
introduction in this room although Tesla
is best known for his invention of the
AC induction motor he spent a great deal
of his life working towards sending
power around the world without wires
Tesla's idea was to place a number of
high voltage towers at strategic points
around the globe each tower would then
capacitively couple power up to the
upper atmosphere which Tesla believed to
be reasonably conductive he based this
on his work with rarefied gases in
vacuum tubes it's also interesting that
Tesla developed this whole scheme
several decades before the ionosphere
was discovered no doubt Tesla would have
been a static to find out that there was
already a prion eyes atmospheric layer
up there in 1899 Tesla started working
on the drive system for its towers this
51 foot diameter fence around the
outside is actually the primary and
secondary coil they drive this tertiary
coil here which produces most of the
voltage and there's Tesla sitting there
he's rather proud of this double
exposure that he did although everybody
back east and the media kind of lost the
notion that it was a double exposure and
then they just think he was crazy this
tertiary coiled here also sends high
voltage up to a raised aerial on the
roof of the building which Tesla used
for measuring coupling to the upper
atmosphere after finishing the drive
system in Colorado Springs
he started construction of this 180
7-foot tall tower at Wardenclyffe on
Long Island this mushroom shaped metal
structure on top is the high voltage
electrode which would a couple power
towards the sky unfortunately Tesla ran
out of money halfway through the project
and never got to throw the switch
ultimately Wardenclyffe was torn down
and scrapped in 1915 to satisfy Tesla's
creditors so would it have worked
there's plenty of arguments on both
sides even today personally I was a
skeptic
after all radio transmitters today are
far more powerful than Wardenclyffe yet
they only deliver fractions of a
microwatt to receiver antennas so how
can Wardenclyffe possibly deliver
kilowatts but then one day I witnessed
uh bizarre electrical accident
I actually caused this accident by
leaving this poor cliff lead Canessa
connected across the primary terminals
of a coil but what's interesting here is
that when the coil burned this clip lead
the coil itself was disconnected from
everything and actually stored away in
the corner of the lab at the time we
were running a similar coil across the
room when somebody started yelling about
smoke after finding the smoldering cliff
lead hanging from the disconnected coil
I just stared at it for a long moment in
disbelief and wondering what in the hell
just happened so of course the first
thing we did was try to recreate the
accident we pulled the stored coil out
and set it up here as the receiving coil
and the other coil we set up as the
transmitting coil and both these coils
are tuned to the same frequency and
instead of a clip lead we gave the
receiving coil 800 watts worth of light
bulbs as a test load now I thought 800
watts would be more than enough
but the receiving coil could actually
drive these way beyond 800 watts
if the transmitting coil got any closer
than 5 meters this made no sense to me
at all since the electric coupling
between these two coils is so incredibly
small it measured about 10 femto farad's
which is 1/100 of a millionth of a
millionth of a farad but later I ran
some detailed circuit simulations which
confirmed that even this amazingly small
amount of coupling can pass dangerous
amounts of power between well to
well-tuned Tesla coils all through the
magic of resonance after this discovery
a friend Mike Kenan felt rather strongly
that light bulbs were a terrible choice
for a test load he thought since of X
should be used to push his lazybone
around
so he built the first the world's first
real Tesla Roadster there's an aerial up
here and this aerial consists of a bunch
of welding rods that form a disc shape
and that establishes an area where it
can collect electric field lines that
ultimately come from the transmitting
coil that energy goes down here to a
little resonant transformer melted on
the frame and this transformer can be
quite small because the operating
frequencies so high the transformer
steps down the voltage to about 200
volts or so and runs this 180 volt Gare
motor over here and then the gear motor
is just linked to the drive axle under
the seat that's all it is here's a short
video clip of the Tesla Roadster in
action at a Maker Faire a while back
note that mike is wearing a heavy
welding clothes he kept complaining
about getting shocks from holding the
steering grips it's too bad we didn't
collect the energy from him as well oh
when the cart starts moving you can see
some lively sparking down here from the
grounding chain that drags behind the
Roadster
[Applause]
he could have kept going around and
around but we had all this other stuff
in the way these little carts that are
rotating in place are smaller prototypes
of Tesla roadsters that whatever the
electric fields high enough they just
start spinning in circles so would
Tesla's Wardenclyffe tower have worked
for near field applications absolutely
even the accidental rig that we had
could deliver over a horsepower a
machine the size a Wardenclyffe could
easily deliver 30 horsepower to local
loads in the area what about far-field
coupling to the ionosphere and beyond
my intuition still says no but then
again you could say my intuition has
already been burned once by my
experience with this in fact the Tesla
could have hosted wireless drag races
that Wardenclyffe over a hundred years
ago more recently however a number of
groups have tried to answer this
question with computer simulations to
simulate the entire cavity between the
ionosphere and the earth and but it's a
huge problem a simulation of this size
presents over 10 billion degrees of
freedom so nobody's quite gotten there
yet being an experimentalist however I'm
convinced that the fastest way to get at
these answers will be simply to build a
resonator tall enough to actually test
the idea so what other strange things
might Tesla have discovered if he was
able to throw the switch on Wardenclyffe
one very likely and completely
unexpected result would have been super
long discharges no doubt Tesla would
have been fascinated by these even as
they short-circuited the output of his
Tower and destroyed nearby equipment
what do we mean by super long discharges
well if we want to make a regular spark
in the laboratory and we have some
suitable high voltage machine classical
electrical theory states that it'll cost
us about two thousand kilovolts per
meter in order to break down the air and
make a nice arc discharge the cost of
breaking down air is well-documented and
modern electrical insulators depend on
this 2,000 kilovolts per meter value to
successfully hold off voltages however
super long discharges are a completely
different beast they use some trick to
reach across huge distances far greater
than 2,000 kilovolts per meter
would normally allow the first man-made
super long discharge occurred in the
1960s at a high-voltage test facility in
Siberia there are the ones shown in this
photo this tower here on the left is
called a Marx generator this one's about
90 feet tall and can produce about five
million volts now normally five million
volts should only arc about this far at
2,000 kilovolts per meter and you can
see the designers of the tower had that
in mind
so imagine their surprise when arcs
started coming on the top of this tower
and shooting across hundreds of meters
in this case across the field hitting
this transmission line blowing out the
insulators on the top of the tower and
even hitting the the streetlights in the
parking lot next to the building these
wild arcs somehow managed to cross these
huge distances with less than 100 kV per
meter that's only a twentieth of what
normal arts require I hate to say this
but we still don't know how super long
discharges pull off this trick we do
know that it only happens at many
millions of volts and in
wide open areas this would be this would
be a really great trick to understand
however since these wild arcs ultimately
limit the things we can do as
fascinating as they were the super long
discharges ultimately killed the
researchers plans to develop multi mega
volt transmission lines and because of
this 1 million volts is about as high as
transmission lines can go these days now
the reason this is sad is because
transmission lines need about 1,000
volts per mile of length in order to be
efficient so a million volt line can
only span about a thousand miles however
a 10 million volt line would be able to
start connecting the continents together
so understanding how to control wild
arcs at multi mega volt levels would
allow renewable energies like solar to
become cost competitive because then you
could build huge solar plants and they
could send power directly to their dark
side of the planet 45 years later the
forests have reclaimed most of the
towers at the facility in Siberia but
the mysteries behind super long
discharges remain
there's also another form of super long
discharges which present us with a
completely different set of problems
storm clouds also have some trick to
initiate very long discharges with
surprisingly weak electric fields the
fields actually measured inside the
storm clouds are only about 50 to 200 kV
per meter a small fraction of the
classic 2,000 kV per meter normally
needed to break down air it's really odd
to think that in the 21st century we
still don't know what this trick is
however a couple russian physicist named
Gourevitch ands ivan came up with a
novel theory to explain this and they
gave it a great name to boot
relativistic runaway breakdown their
theory starts with an Olympic field in
the middle of the cloud arranged at some
arbitrary angle usually they're mostly
vertical now this field doesn't have to
be strong enough to break down air it
only has to be strong enough to
accelerate free electrons a cosmic ray
enters the electric field area and
strikes an atom under the right
conditions if it hits it just right the
cosmic ray will knock off electrons at
relativistic velocities now a curious
property of relativistic electrons is
that they're moving so fast that they
actually shrink they effectively shrink
due to their warped space-time which
significantly reduces their friction in
air this allows them to accelerate to
near the speed of light until they
eventually do hit other atoms and knock
off more relativistic electrons
eventually starting a chain reaction now
the theory predicts that if the electric
field reaches a critical strength of 200
kV per meter and spans a critical
distance of 80 meters then this
Avalanche can build up enough to the
point where it can start a classical
lightning discharge so in the late 1990s
Reacher's we researchers started
searching storm clouds for telltale
gamma rays that would lend support to
the theory but for many years they
couldn't find anything at all it turns
out they were looking from the wrong
direction about ten years later NASA's
Fermi gamma-ray telescope made an
amazing accidental discovery described
here in this video
at any given moment about 1,800
thunderstorms aren't progress somewhere
on the globe new observations by NASA's
Fermi gamma-ray Space Telescope show the
thunderstorms make antimatter the
process starts with a terrestrial
gamma-ray flash or TGF an intense pulse
of gamma rays originating from
thunderstorms
these dots mark TGIF's observed by
fairways gamma-ray burst monitor during
the spacecraft's first eight months of
operations researchers estimate that
there may be as many as 500 TGFs each
day on December 14th 2009 as ferry
passed over Egypt it spotted a TGIF
produced by a thunderstorm in Zambia the
TGF was over the spacecraft's horizon
where Fermi couldn't see it so how could
fairly have detected it scientists or
have 80g enough process begins the
thunderstorms intense electrical field
electrons within this field become
accelerated upward above the storm where
the air is thin the electrons can ramp
up to speeds nearly as fast as the speed
of light when they ultra-fast electrons
encounter an atom they emit gamma rays
very rarely one of these gamma ray
photons grazes anatomy and transforms
into a pair of particles one an electron
is normal matter the other is antimatter
the electrons opposite called a positron
the gamma rays travel in straight lines
but the charged particles spiral along
lines of Earth's magnetic field and that
was the route to fare me the particles
created by the TGF wrote upward on
magnetic field lines and then struck the
spacecraft the positrons annihilated
when they struck electrons at Fermi
creating a flash of gamma rays for an
instant fairnie became a gamma ray
source and set up its own detectors a
fraction of a second later some of the
particles were bounced back along the
same magnetic field line they again
passed through semi and again the noose
gamma-rays the spacecraft is observed
this phenomenon and at least four other
occasions so the next time lightning
flashes and Thunder roars remember you
may be witnessing antimatter in the
making so thunderstorms really do
produce both gamma rays and antimatter
but the funny discovery raised more
questions than answers why do the gamma
rays head upwards rather than down are
there other effects that work here that
we haven't considered and perhaps most
importantly are there ways that we could
hack this fantastic gain mechanism it
would be incredibly useful for instance
if we had the ability to turn off
lightning over populated areas these
answers have eluded us for decades since
floating around with instruments at the
exact right place and right time inside
a storm cloud is practically impossible
now I wonder if anyone here looking at
this problem has had the same thought as
me that the best way to get at these
answers is to simply recreate this
critical electric field here on the
ground where we can actually measure
what happens in close detail now an
electric field that's two hundred
thousand volts per meter and eighty
meters in length is only about 16
million volts total from end to end so
I've spent a lot of effort working on
possible ways to generate such a field
and I'm happy to report that it's not
completely crazy to do the most
practical approach I found so far it's
to set up to 120 foot tall Tesla towers
it's faced about 300 feet apart mm-hmm
at just eight million volts per tower
oppositely phased the space between the
towers can produce the critical field
needed to start relative relativistic
runaway breakdown now modern structural
plastics that you would make these
towers out of only support about seven
thousand volts per inch outdoors and
that's if they're well cared for
so each tower needs to be a minimum of
about twelve stories in height to
support this much voltage this high it
also places the runaway breakdown zone
safely above the ground where it's
easier to view with instruments here's a
few interesting numbers that fall out of
the full-scale machine design the design
target for the output voltage is
actually about twenty percent higher
than the minimum sixteen MV required by
the theory and that's because
historically large electrical machines
and large research machines always
encounter some intriguing corner case
that's just out of reach and I know many
times including the Tevatron where they
wish they could turn it to eleven the
primary drive system for each tower
includes 12 stations and each station
has an array of the largest 6,500 volt
transistors available in order to
produce this aggregate primary drive
currents now we're used to processors
containing millions of transistors but a
single one of these transistors this is
the size of a phone book the transistors
that we'll use here are currently used
to power high-speed electric trains so
to show that a 121 foot tall Tesla coil
isn't completely crazy I thought I
should demonstrate a one-third scale
model of one tower so for the last five
years
I've been building this 40-foot tall
fully functional scale prototype now
even the scale prototype will be more
than twice as large as the largest
operating Tesla coil ever built
so for me to build this without any
funding this prototype necessarily
explores new design ideas that
significantly reduce the cost of
construction and operation among these
are a fully collapsible tower design and
a modular massively parallel primary
drive system to give you a rough idea of
what this coil might look like running
at two hundred forty thousand watts
here's a short clip of a coil that I
built about 20 years ago running at
about eighty thousand watts this coil
was called electrum and I built it as an
art project for the gibbs art farm in
new zealand electrum is currently the
world's largest Tesla coil in this clip
you can see electron reaching out to a
streetlight that was unfortunately
located too close to the tower in the
world at full power the RK discharges
reach out to 50 feet from the top
electrode the unusual serum electrode
allows the person to actually stand
inside the electrode at full power aside
from being incredibly fun writing the
electrode
millions of volts provided a rare
educational experience the new 40-foot
Tower will run at about three times this
output power here's how the new 40 foot
coil tower looks now in its a fully
collapsed eight the secondary winding
breaks into eight parts and they're all
nested here on top of each other the
entire machine is about 95% complete now
however this photo was taken at a key
moment the coil is leaving the lab space
for the last time and going to a storage
facility I recently lost my lab space
here that I've had for the last eight
years when real estate developers from
New York bought the entire American
steel site you might imagine their
response upon seeing my workspace for
the first time I knew I was in trouble
when one of them asked will all of this
stuff affect my DNA so I was promptly
kicked out along with many other
workshops and artists there including
Gary Wilson and Karen who Salido the
artists who actually founded American
steel studios now eight years ago it was
pretty easy to find another industrial
space but nowadays even undesirable
spots like American steel are being
scooped up by developers so right now
everything's in storage and the project
is pretty much dead in the water
but I have a plan to replace this lab
space with one that can avoid the
hazards of gentrification the plan is to
get a custom cargo trailer and outfit it
with all the tower components
instruments and a workshop since the
tower itself is fully collapsible the
entire system can pack into a single
18-foot trailer there's many great
desolate spots around the Bay Area that
would make perfect test sites
but they don't have usable buildings or
utilities however a self-contained
mobile lab could just roll into one of
these sites set up perform experiments
and then roll out all without needing
any building space administrative
overhead or hookups storing a trailer is
also much much easier than finding
reliable lab space in Oakland these days
so right now the new 40 foot Tesla tower
is almost ready to fire up but
everything's in storage until the mobile
lab is ready in order to get the 18 foot
cargo trailer I started a fundraiser at
elllo.org to make the fundraiser
interesting I've added some unusual
perks like frozen lightning an Electra
mater II by Alberto Chu and a special
high power demo of the 40-foot coil when
it's ready it's been 10 years since I've
hosted a public demo so maybe it's time
for one more if you're interested in
this kind of stuff check out the
fundraiser it's at elllo.org
at this point I guess I'd like to open
the Florida
Zandar
we're just gonna do a little bit of
stage change here so i'm i'm curious
greg i I mentioned srl and I know that
you've worked with them a little bit and
so I didn't really close that loop but I
you know the the early forms of survival
research labs were very much about kind
of pirate science as well and now you're
creating your own savage engineering
pirate ship for science for lightning
science and did was your work with them
kind of good inspire some of this
thinking or is it just really based on
necessity of oh yeah working with us or
ill allowing one to experience social
scenarios that you don't normally get to
experience and to know to discover that
the fabric that society is made out of
it's actually kind of fragile and goes
away in certain places I wasn't there
with mark but I remember one story where
he needed a big winch that was out at in
a railroad yard somewhere and so he went
out to get it and started unbolting it
just in broad daylight and the police
came by and said hey what are you doing
he's I'm taking this railroad winds I
need it for a performance and they said
well you can't do that get out of here
so they ran him off and and they were
just flabbergasted that he was doing it
in broad daylight as if he deserved it
as an artist yes well the coiner of the
term obtaining them as far as right now
and i'm i think what's what's also
interesting is that i mean you're trying
to get to a fundamental in a very
comment what's obviously a common
phenomenon of lightning that is amazing
that we don't understand and it always
seems in these cases that an obscure
russian research paper is the answer and
how did you come across this theory and
we're
did you where did you find it oh well I
I monitored geophysics especially
anything having to do with the natural
electrical phenomena like the global
electrical circuit sprites things like
that and they published it a little bit
earlier but they published it widely in
2005 and my first reaction to that was I
can't imagine gamma rays coming out of a
lightning storm because that's a very
classical effect right and then later on
when Dwyer added the supplement of
positrons I said okay I'm not going to
believe that antimatter comes out of
lightning storms that's just too much
but then Fermi happened and everybody's
still scratching their heads interesting
and I think what's also really
interesting here and I think gets us to
a kind of a global impact is this idea
that that by kind of cracking some of
this phenomena some of our problems such
as energy storage where you can bring
power to the other side of the world
really starts changing the landscape of
our entire power infrastructure is to
have you in your normal work I know that
you've worked in some of these spaces do
you want to talk a little bit about
about that and how some of these
alternative energy powers might be
affected by that oh yeah well right now
I used to work at Makani and they make
these special windmills that actually
eight bladed acrobatic planes that
circle on it yeah some of you remember
or Saul Griffith who's speaking and
spoken twice and our other series is the
founder of Makani right and the thing
holding back renewables right now is
storage the cost of storage is just too
much so you end up with places like in
Germany where they had so much they had
a perfect storm of solar and wind to
where the price of electricity went
negative because they couldn't ship
anywhere and that problem is going to
get worse and worse as more solar comes
online however it you had some way of
selling that power directly to dark or
calm areas for the price of electricity
is high then suddenly it makes sense and
they become competitive with other forms
like natural gas right I mean an
intercontinental electric grid yes
change the landscape considerably we
already do that in the United States
where we shift power from hot hot places
to cold places and from one time zone to
the next yeah the biggest line in the
u.s. right now is the Pacific in ertai
it comes from the hydroelectric plants
in Washington and feeds Los Angeles
right Los Angeles is just draws it in
from everywhere and that's a 1 million
volt DC line at 2,500 amps and that's
about as high as I go and that that just
makes the run from Washington to Los
Angeles right I remember the coal-fired
power plant that was going to go up near
Gerlach Nevada I was also going to feed
LA as well when it took LA saying they
didn't want to add that to the playa for
them did not build that but and the why
do you why do you think you're kind of
alone in this space and why is where's
where's the NASA research lab that's
that's doing this I mean I know that you
work you know for modern tech companies
in your day job doing high voltage
research so you know it's obviously need
for your amazing skills but nobody is
trying to figure out the fundamentals of
lightning or the worldwide power grid
strangely well else is busy doing en
power and things like that to violate
basic physics and if you want to look at
what people are interested in just go to
Kickstarter or IndieGoGo and look at the
things that are raising all the money
it's like for a little clip on for your
iPhone nobody's really interested in you
know pure research no like they used to
be there's so many other things to think
about and do
and excel at right yeah and we were
talking about this earlier but from I
remember a conversation with Saul
Griffith he he basically a kind of
reverse engineer that the Google
research budget is now larger than DARPA
and clearly they're looking for
different kinds of winds than DARPA
would be in pure research so that's a
it's an interesting problem when you
have I think people especially from the
software background working in the
physical sciences and hopefully looking
for the same kind of scaling effects
yeah software people working in physics
sound like a fish out of water what do
you mean I can't undo that for questions
and we have a microphone because we have
people tuned in from our online audience
so please do wait for the microphone so
raise your hand and Michael here will
get my microphone to you Andrew
one of the weirdest Wikipedia articles
I've ever stumbled upon was ball
lightning it's like historic phenomena
with all these different accounts of
lightning like entering a room going
around and then leaving a room I was
just wondering if there's science on it
or if you had a take on it well a lot of
that's hard to unwind the anecdotal
evidence sometimes it's just persistence
of vision where there was a flash where
it hit the ground that was in their
retina just off-center a vision this was
they try to look at it at wanders now
that's one explanation other than that
there hasn't been much progress however
you can make plasmids in your microwave
oven have you ever tried that you mean
putting a metal fork and your microwave
and turning it on well not a medal for
it that'll double spark but that's not
what you want you take like a ceramic
cup and turn it upside down and then
find some thin carbon mesh they call it
carbon veil
and put a little strip in there on top
of the thing and set the microwave oven
on just in our microwave upstairs okay
keep going yeah you don't want to use it
you know you don't want to do this and
one that you normally cook food in
because and what you'll get are these
balls of plasma about this big around
there like orange white and I'll just
start floating around in there going and
there's they're balls of conductive
material because they're humming at the
60 Hertz that the magnetron is running
at and inevitably they since they're
lighter than air they hit the ceiling
they bounce off the ceiling and before
long all of the paint is peeled off the
top so don't try it at home try it in
somebody else's home yeah and I don't
have a good explanation for them it I
haven't looked deeply for one it's just
one of those just one of those things at
the bar okay my question goes back to
the beginning of your talk with Tesla's
transmission experiment he had one tower
what was the phenomenon he was hoping to
see that would show that his idea was
working it's unclear to me he had plans
to set up another tower in the UK
somewhere and it'd be a smaller one just
to listen so he was actually trying to
get that signal all the way across the
Atlantic he was trying to get power
across the Atlantic yeah he had told JP
Morgan that it was going to be a radio
station
and that's kind of how things fell apart
nice you have any other questions don't
over yes hi
I'm sure there's a lot of pushback from
Big Oil and maybe now what might be
called big wind and big hydro but how as
a community can we help the progression
of this type of research when there's so
much opposition with big money well he
has an IndieGoGo campaign right now so
you can fund that but I'll let I mean I
think I mean are you do you feel as
though you're hitting resistance so much
is just apathy more apathy
I mean I've talked with a number of
institutions and people about doing this
research and several are very excited
and they say as soon as you have it
built we want to come and do research
very few philanthropic organizations
want to give out capital equipment money
gotcha
we've got a question from the livestream
about someone who saw the marks
generator at the Museum of Science and
Industry in Chicago I think this is many
years back where they would split two by
fours with lightnings and a huge
thunderclap through the museum where do
marks and Cockcroft Walton generators
fit into this work is it the can you
tell us what those are and are they a
similar thing or something that it's
there for a different technology Mark's
generators can generate millions of
volts and if you load them up with
capacitance they'll split two by fours a
coke off the Walton generator is a
little bit different a Marx generator
works by charging a bunch of capacitors
in parallel and then you have some means
to suddenly connect them in series and
they form a high voltage where as a
co-prophet you're using diodes arranged
in a zigzag all the way up the
capacitors and it acts like a bucket
brigade and it just shuttles a charge
all the way to the top and
some amount of time it charges up to
full voltage and both of these schemes
can make millions of volts however I
want to make eight million volts but I
have to do it cheaply a Marx generator
per volt that cost way more than a Tesla
coil because if you make the Tesla coil
right it's mostly air it's just a
winding that does this whereas the the
Marx Bank has all these capacitors all
the way up there so it's a structure
that holds a lot of weight and that
structure also has to be a good
insulator very expensive is that what
that structure back again back to Russia
there was that structure that that
Russia built that would look like a
whole series of diodes going up in and I
think you talked about it at one point
when we were first talking about the
stock that it it ended up being too
close to some grounding source oh the
the big White Tower yeah yeah that was a
March generator
it was a bunch of capacitors I think
that one had 90 or 100 stages in series
and and the spark gaps were all lined up
through the center if you get up in
there look at it it looks really cool
because there's just this vanishing
point of spark gaps and they're all
lined up in series because when the
first one flashes they follow in a chain
reaction the ultraviolet light from one
of them lands on the electrodes of the
other and actually helps break it down
and you also mentioned about turning off
lightning which I thought was
interesting I was just out at the clock
say where we're building the clock and
we have a big huge crane tower at the
top that's attached to all of us humans
effectively because we're all on the
crane platform and whenever there was
lightning within five miles we had to
stop working and and obviously lightning
causes destruction around the world on
some level and fires forest fires for
better or worse depending on where you
are what do you think that there's a
plausible scenario for being able to
control lightning on that level I think
it's worth looking at because as I
mentioned lightning uses this gain
mechanism it doesn't have enough feel to
generate lightning the start
but this relativistic electron avalanche
has a net gain and usually something
like that that has gained it's pretty
easy to wreck it and all you have to do
is wreck it to reconcile that change to
stop the chain reaction and not the
Lightning is that theory the widely
accepted theory at this point or is that
it's not still a fairly it's one of them
a terrific ins eivin's runaway breakdown
is one of the main contenders however it
doesn't explain a few things apparently
it doesn't have quite enough gain to
actually start a real lightning strike
which is anywhere from thirty thousand
to one hundred twenty thousand amps
however Dwyer came up with a really
novel mechanism where the gamma rays
facing downwards can produce positron
electron pairs just like in the NASA
video but heading downwards and if you
make a positron in that electric field
it heads back upstream because it's
positively charged and history is it can
make it upstream far enough to where it
eventually does hit something and
annihilates it'll produce more
relativistic electrons upstream again
and it forms kind of this positronic
feedback loop that could greatly
increase the current in the Avalanche
that was the point where I said no I I
can't believe positrons can can you
explain a little bit more about your
design so you should the collapsed
version of your coil but it inflate can
you explain how it inflates and how that
works and how you arrived that design
what some of the advantages are how
you're doing it yeah well essentially I
needed a four-story structure that can
hold a winding five feet in diameter all
the way up there plus a big top
electrode and the cheapest way to make a
structure is to use all tension elements
don't use any compression elements like
in airplanes they try to make everything
as tension as much as possible like a
like a stretched skin wing so the main
structure in the center is an in-flight
double cylinder and everything's in
tension except for the air which is in
the middle that's under compression
there's nothing else in there it's just
all air and so you're using basically
modern jumpy house technology that's
right
in fact the fabric the fabric is
straight out of bounce houses we will
learn how lightning works because about
any bouncy house and we'll make up front
what's even more remarkable is that
entire 40-foot Tower I managed to get
that through the sewing machine in my
house to sew it all together
so by some amazing feat of topology it
all fit through there opening this big
so after listening to this brilliant man
talk about his life's work is there not
someone in San Francisco in this room or
listening online considering how
interesting it is and how important it
is isn't there someone who can fund this
trivial amount of money that he's
looking for I sure hope so people with
real money have safeguards against too
much fun Daniel so as long as we're
talking about lighting suppression what
about the Congress what about what about
like energy harvesting from lightning
and is there any serious thought there's
just just overwhelmed anything at the
light ministry lightning is really hard
to get a handle on is that this really
awkward impedance it's very high voltage
and then also I occurred but really high
voltage and you have maybe 350 million
volts there that you can harvest so to
get any appreciable amount of that you
have to build a tower that can store 350
million volts it's pretty easy to make
say a 10 million volt tower and so you
can get 10 a 10 divided by 350 you can
get that much of the lightning strike in
your 10 million volt hour now you have
this 10 million volts that you have to
disassemble
down to a little voltage that you can
use and plug into the grid and so it's
it's just a really awkward energy to get
at almost like tidal energy is awkward
in the other way it's it's all movement
and no pressure and lightning is all
pressure and little movement Gary so a
minute ago you mentioned a feedback loop
in the middle of your talk you said
there was a factor of about 20 to 1 that
doesn't isn't really explained by normal
I guess
so does that feedback loop answer the 20
to 1 yes Dwyer presented numbers for his
positronic feedback loop easily reaches
the 20 to 1 whereas the normal
relativistic runaway breakdown Avalanche
doesn't quite make it and we see
positrons come out so maybe it matches
the theory I think there's still a lot
of unknowns there well I want to thank
you for your presentation and I really
encourage everyone to check out your
three letter domain I think you probably
auction that off for what you need for
the rest to see you know the Lords of
discipline the heavy metal band I'm sure
looking for it but actually actually
when I got this URL
I wanted LOD calm but it has already
taken so I looked up who LOD comm was
and I ultimately figured out it was the
Legion of Doom and so I sent them an
email saying oh hi I'm your next-door
neighbor at elllo.org
so you delete you to doom huh and the
guy was kind of like yeah that was us
but we've all grown up now we have real
jobs
it's a UNIX consulting group of course
it is so anyway thank you and I
encourage everyone to check it out and
and hopefully we are going to see this
project both funded and then actually
get to see it in real life and see if
the obscure Russian paper is the truly
the answer once again Craig's gonna be
around here to answer some more
questions and then hopefully run some of
the tools in the back and Michael do you
have a yeah and your I think Greg is
you're getting demos going of your of
the 40-foot one did you do you want to
say something about about that as that's
coming out yeah the plant is once I got
the mobile lab set up where I can
actually bring it somewhere and run it I
would like to do some demos and I'd like
to invite specifically the people here
tonight to come see a demo right and
here is a long no challenge going for
all of our speakers thank you so much
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]